[Music]  you know a lot of award shows have their  own caddy correspondent to comment on  red carpet fashions well the audiences  are no exception please welcome our own  audiences fashion assassin  james sinclair st wallins  [Applause]  okay okay  let the pain begin bring on the first  victim  oh god  look at you  mr nose ring  if you're here who's in your garage  welding motorcycle  you must have bought that shirt at the  gap the gap between glaucoma and total  blindness  next  oh  someone carjacked a clown car  that outfit's the worst thing i've ever  seen and i've seen every catherine heigl  movie  next  oh god  look at this mess  nice hair braids swiss smith  that shirt is so ugly your sleeves  committed suicide  i can't take anymore come on queen  daniel let's go write mean tweets about  renee zellweger  [Applause]  [Music]  terrible guys  [Applause]